TO SEE WHAT IS OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
>> Tucker: KEN GREENWALD IS
COEDTOR AT THE GREEN PRESS.
GLEN, WHERE IS THE DIVERSITY IN
GENERAL.
>> THIS IS ONE OF THE PROBLEMS
THAT ALLOWED THE MEDIA TO GO SO
FAR OFF THE RAILS.
ESPECIALLY THOSE TWO CABLE
NETWORKS AND ALSO NEWSPAPERS,
PRETTY MUCH PROHIBITED DISSENT
FROM EVER BEING HEARD.
SO THEY CONSTANTLY FED EACH
OTHER THESE CONSPIRACY THEORIES
AND TOLD EACH THEY ARE THEY WERE
ON THE RIGHT TRACK EVERY TIME HE
ADVANCED IT FURTHER.
NEVER REALLY HAD TO CONFRONT
ANYBODY WHO PRESENTED OR
CHALLENGED THEM IN ANY WAY.
I'VE SPENT THE LAST TWO YEARS
DEBATING EVERYONE CAN I FIND WHO
HAD DIFFERENT VIEWS THAN I HAD
ON THIS WHOLE SAGA, I WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THE THINGS I WAS
SAYING WERE SCRUTINIZED.
THAT'S WHAT THEY AVOIDED, THAT'S
THE REASON WHY THEY WENT SO FAR
OFF THE RAILS.
FIRST TIME I SAW YOUR NEW SHOW,
WHEN YOU HAD ADAM SCHIFF ON THE
SET FOR 12 MINUTES AND YOU WENT
BACK AND FORTH AND DEBATED.
WHAT THE OTHER NETWORKS REFUSE
TO DO.
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE IN SUCH A
BUBBLE WHERE THEY HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE WORLD.
>> Tucker: I THINK AFTER TODAY,
THE FOCUS, MY FOCUS WOULD SHIFT
TO HOW DO YOU FIX THIS?
YOU NEED A FUNCTIONING MEDIA,
EVEN IF I DON'T AGREE WITH THE
PEOPLE IN IT OR DON'T LIKE THEM
OR DON'T LIKE WHO THEY VOTE FOR.
YOU STILL NEED ADULTS COVERING
NEWS AND KEEPING THE POWERFUL,
YOU KNOW, UNDER A CLOSE EYE.
HOW DO YOU FIX THIS?
THEY'RE SO DISCREDITED AND
BROKEN AND UNWILLING TO ADMIT
IT.
WHAT DO YOU DO NOW?
WITH THE AMERICAN MEDIA.
>> AFTER THE IRAQ WAR WHEN THE
MEDIA HELPED THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION CONVINCE THE
COUNTRY TO GO TO WAR BASED ON
FALSE CLAIMS ABOUT THE WEAPONS
PROGRAM OF SADDAM HUSSEIN, THERE
WAS SOME SELF-REFLECTION, SOME
INTROSPECTION, SOME JOURNALISTIC
INSPECTION ABOUT STATEMENTS MADE
AND ATTEMPTS TO REFORM.
HERE I DON'T SEE THAT.
IF YOU LISTEN TO THE MEDIA
DISCOURSE, OUTSIDE OF A FEW
CIRCLES, THEY'VE JUST PUT
COLLUSION AND CONSPIRACY AND ALL
OF THOSE CONSPIRACY THEORIES
THEY'VE ENDORSED FLUSHED IT DOWN
THE TOILET LIKE THEY DON'T EXIST
AND SEAMLESSLY SHIFTED TO
OBSTRUCTION.
THEN THEY'RE CONFLATING THEM TO
CLAIM THAT THEY WERE RIGHT ALL
ALONG.
THAT IS REALLY THE ALARMING
THING.
IN A LOT OF WAYS DONALD TRUMP
BROKE THE BRAINS OF A LOT OF
PEOPLE, PARTICULARLY PEOPLE IN
THE MEDIA WHO BELIEVE THAT
TELLING LIES, INVENTING
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, IT'S ALL
JUSTIFIED TO STOP THIS
UNPARALLELED MEN AS.
THAT'S A GOOD THING FOR ACTIVIST
TO THINK AND REALLY BAD THING
FOR A JOURNALIST TO THINK.
>> Tucker: YOU DON'T SOUND
HOPEFUL IT CAN BE REPAIRED.
>> YOU WERE TALKING JUST NOW
ABOUT IMPEACHMENT.
ALREADY, ADAM SCHIFF AND STENNY
HOYER HAVE SAID THEY DON'T
INTEND TO PURSUE IMPEACHMENT
CHARGES.
THAT TELLS YOU ALL YOU NEED KNOW
ABOUT THE ASSESSMENT OF THE
POLITICAL VALUE.
THEY HAVE BEEN DISCREDITED.
I THINK IF DEMOCRATS ON THE HILL
KNOW THIS WHOLE THING HAS COULD
LAMBED AS A HOAX HOPEFULLY THE
MEDIA ALLIES OF THEIRS WILL COME
TO THAT SAME REALIZATION AND
HAVE A LITTLE BIT HAVE SHAME
ABOUT WHAT THEY'VE DONE TO THEIR
CRED ABOUT IT.
BILT.
AND I'M -- CREDIBILITY.
I'M HOPEFUL THOUGH I DON'T THINK
IT'S INEVITABLE.
>> Tucker: YOU NEVER GROW IF
YOU'RE NOT ASHAMED.
I NEVER LEARNED ANYTHING EXCEPT